We're not controlling for differences in memory capabilities due to gender in
this particular test. To do this, we could divide the group into males and
females, and then see how sleep influences memory in both groups. We want the
amount of sleep to vary amongst individuals, so that we can see how their memory
is related to that. We are controlling for variation in people's individual
memory capabilities,, because by using this same person twice, we're doing
what's called a within-subject design. That way we can see how sleep influences
memory for this same person. And by using this same person twice, we're keeping
a lot of other things constant, including this variation in people's individual
memory capabilities. We're also not controlling for the time of day in this
study, but this would be a good thing to add on to the within-subject study. We
could tell our subjects to sleep a lot, then take the memory test at the same
time the next day as everyone else, like 3 o'clock. Then again, we can tell
people to sleep a little, and then take the memory test at the same time of day,
again at 3 o'clock.